Transcription: Mohand Habchi
Relecteur: Antoine THOLLON
J'ai choisi un métier qui me permet
d'aller là où vous ne pouvez pas aller.
Je suis photoreporter.
Mon métier, c'est aussi de vous faire voir
ce que, parfois,
vous n'avez pas envie de voir.
Paradoxalement, mon métier,
c'est de vous faire voir le gris.
Tout a commencé pour moi
en Afghanistan en 2004.
J'ai débarqué, des préjugés,
des idées préconçues plein la tête,
et franchement, ça m'allait trop bien.
L'année d'après, j'ai été
dans un attentat suicide.
J'en suis ressortie
miraculeusement indemne
mais j'ai repris la réalité
en pleine poire.
En 2006, j'ai été embarquée
avec les soldats américains.
Je ne les connaissais pas
mais je ne pouvais pas les voir,
je les détestais.
Pour moi, c'était des brutes
qui malmenaient les Afghans.
Et puis coincés ensemble, on attend.
On attend que quelque chose se passe,
et à force, je commence
à les trouver sympas, marrants,
je commence même à m'attacher à eux.
Mais un soir, Mike, 19 ans à peine,
s'esclaffe et me raconte :
« Un jour, j'ai tiré
une roquette sur un mec.
Je crois que c'était un taliban.
Il s'est transformé en torche vivante
et a couru comme un poulet fou. »
Tout le monde se marre.
Moi, ça ne me fait pas rire,
mais je comprends qu'à force,
la guerre déshumanise l'ennemi
et que l'autre en face n'est plus rien.
Pourtant, cet autre
en face, je l'ai rencontré.
Avec Eric de la Varenne et Claire Billet,
nous avons été les premiers occidentaux
à rencontrer les Talibans.
Avec Claire, nous avons dû
revêtir notre burqa.
Alors moi, pour faire passer
la vision engrillagée,
j'ai un petit truc sympa.
Je fous mon iPod à fond
avec « Like a Virgin » de Madonna.
Ça, c'est ma petite revanche.
Après une longue route
parcourue en silence
et dans une chaleur étouffante,
les voici enfin, ils sont là, ce sont eux.
Les jeunes combattants
se précipitent vers nous
et nous accueillent avec
des gâteaux et des jus de fruit,
puis se mettent à faire
des selfies avec nous en se marrant.
Ils nous sortent
leur petit répertoire d'anglais,
on finit tous pas se détendre
et puis tout à coup,
(Musique)
la sonnerie de portable de l'un d'eux.
(Rires)
C'était eux, les talibans ?
Alors en fait, j'ai été plus choquée
par les points communs qu'il existait
entre les jeunes GI américains
et les jeunes combattants insurgés.
Alors j'ai fait le choix
peut-être choquant,
perturbant mais que je trouve pertinent,
de mettre en avant
les similitudes de ces ennemis,
ces ennemis qui pourtant
ne se considèrent même plus
comme des hommes.
Mais c'est une guerre,
et dans une guerre, il y a des victimes.
Le 18 août 2008,
dix soldats français et leur fixeur
sont tués dans une embuscade à Uzbin.
Je suis envoyée pour
couvrir le coté afghan.
Par expérience, je sais
qu’après chaque attaque,
il y a une riposte aérienne.
Trois villages proches du lieu
de l'embuscade ont été bombardés.
Il y a eu des victimes,
des victimes civiles.
Il faut que je me rende sur place,
mais la zone est contrôlée
par les talibans,
il faut donc que je leur demande
leur autorisation,
et alors là c'est parti.
Une burqa, une longue route, une escorte,
et puis le trac, j'ai peur.
Et tout à coup,
des silhouettes dévalent la colline.
Ce sont eux.
J'explique au chef mon projet,
mais il refuse.
J'insiste, et puis je remarque
que l'un d'entre eux
porte une arme qui m'a l'air
tout à fait moderne.
Je lui demande ce que c'est,
il me répond que c'est l'une des armes
prises sur le corps d'un des soldats tués.
En fait, sans le savoir,
je me retrouve en face des insurgés
responsables de l'embuscade.
Alors, pour avoir fait ces photos
que vous venez de voir,
on m'a menacée de mort.
Mes parents ont reçu des lettres
vraiment désagréables
et ont même perdu des amis.
On m'a accusée d'avoir payé
50 000 euros les talibans.
Bon, c'est évidemment stupide
et complètement irréaliste.
D'une part, on ne paye jamais
les personnes que nous photographions
pour des raisons éthiques,
d'autre part,
nos reporters ne se trimbaleraient
jamais avec une telle somme.
On m'a aussi accusée
de faire leur propagande.
Alors là, ne soyons pas dupes.
À partir du moment où un groupe,
que ce soit les talibans ou même l'armée,
décide de consacrer
du temps à une journaliste,
c'est bien qu'ils ont
un message à faire passer.
On m'a aussi accusée
d'être antipatriotique
ou de trahir mon pays.
Pourquoi ? Parce que j'ai osé
montrer le visage de l'ennemi ?
Alors je ne pense pas avoir manqué
de respect envers les soldats tombés,
même si je comprends que ça ait pu
être difficile pour leurs familles,
mais certains parents m'ont remerciée
parce qu'ils avaient soif de vérité,
même douloureuse.
En aucun cas, je ne veux
essayer de justifier
les actes ignobles
commis par les talibans.
Je veux juste vous donner
un maximum d'infos
pour que vous puissiez juger
en connaissance de cause.
Alors c'est vrai,
ça serait beaucoup plus simple
un monde où il n'y a
que des gentils et des méchants,
mais c'est une guerre,
et dans une guerre, c'est rarement le cas.
Une guerre, ce n'est ni blanc ni noir,
c'est sale,
c'est gris.
D'ailleurs, ces zones de gris,
je les ai rencontrées
dans bien d'autres pays.
Notamment dans le delta du Niger.
Une zone pourrie par le pétrole.
Plus rien ne pousse, plus rien à pêcher,
pendant que les potentats locaux
s'en foutent plein les poches.
C'est là qu'est arrivé le MEND :
Mouvement d'Émancipation
du Delta du Niger.
Ils se cachent dans la mangrove
et leur truc à eux, c'est le kidnapping,
les attaques des plates-formes pétrolières
et le contrôle du marché noir du pétrole.
Avec Manon Quérouil,
la journaliste avec laquelle je travaille,
nous avions très envie
de rencontrer Ateke,
l'un des grands chefs de ces prétendus
Robin des Bois des temps modernes.
Et puis en guise de Robin des Bois,
vous avez vu,
on est plutôt tombé sur un petit
rondouillard en manque de charisme.
Affalé dans son sofa, il nous a reçues
avec une bouteille de Veuve Clicquot tiède.
En fait, depuis quelques temps,
c'est beaucoup plus simple pour eux
parce qu'ils sont directement
payés par les compagnies pétrolières
pour ne pas les attaquer.
Du coup, ils ont plein de fric,
ils s'emmerdent et voilà.
Les filles des alentours,
attirées par la poule aux œufs d'or,
viennent distraire ces messieurs.
D'ailleurs ce petit rondouillard
a jeté son dévolu sur ma copine.
J'ai dû jouer la grande sœur,
lui expliquer qu'en France
avant de coucher, on se marie.
Bon, il a eu l'air d'un peu en douter,
mais a finalement accepté
de nous renvoyer en ville
pour que nous allions faire
nos petites emplettes de filles.
Autant vous dire qu'Ateke
attend toujours sa fiancée envolée.
Ateke, longtemps ennemi
public numéro un
et aujourd'hui l'un des amis intimes
du nouveau président, Jonathan Goodluck,
et il paraît, l'un des hommes
les plus riches du pays.
Alors en fait de Robin des Bois,
ce sont des bandits comme les autres ?
Le noir et blanc, c'est pour les contes,
la vraie vie, elle, est en couleur.
C'est plus perturbant,
c'est plus compliqué,
mais c'est plus intéressant.
D'ailleurs, la complexité des situations,
le Nigéria en connaît beaucoup.
J'ai pu encore m'en rendre en compte
dans un reportage dans le nord
sur les traces de Boko Haram.
Avec Manon,
nous n'avons pas pu les rencontrer,
mais nous nous sommes rendu compte
que les racines de Boko Haram
étaient beaucoup plus complexes
et beaucoup plus anciennes
qu'il n'y paraissait.
En fait, depuis plus
de dix ans maintenant,
une véritable guerre sévit
entre l'armée nigériane
et Boko Haram.
Et c'est une guerre sans merci,
où c'est œil pour œil, dent pour dent.
L'armée nigériane incendie des madrassas,
Boko Haram brûle des écoles.
L'armée nigériane enlève
des femmes et des enfants
suspectés d'être liés
aux membres de la secte,
Boko Haram enlève des jeunes filles.
La vérité, c'est que le nord du pays
a été complètement abandonné
par le gouvernement du sud.
Les nordistes, laissés pour compte,
sont bien entendu devenus amers.
Boko Haram a su utiliser cette rancœur
pour appâter les jeunes,
et le comportement presque criminel
de cette armée corrompue
a conduit à une série d'abominations
les plus tragiques
les unes que les autres,
jusqu'à l’enlèvement
on s'en souvient, de 219 lycéennes,
ce qui a enfin fini
par attirer notre attention.
Alors, entendons-nous bien.
Rien de ce que nous avons pu découvrir
ne justifie l'enlèvement
et la mise en esclavage de jeunes filles.
Aller à la rencontre de l'ennemi,
ce n'est pas l'excuser,
et je ne veux pas me faire
le porte-parole des talibans,
du MEND ou de Boko Haram.
Je ne veux en aucun cas essayer
de justifier ou excuser
leurs agissements ignobles,
je veux juste mieux
vous les faire connaître
pour que vous puissiez penser en sachant,
en connaissance de cause.
Parce que je crois que parfois,
mieux connaître, mieux comprendre,
c'est aider à résoudre,
et que bien des erreurs
auraient pu être évitées
avec une meilleure connaissance
des gens et du terrain.
Alors on voit bien que
le noir et blanc ne fonctionne pas,
parce qu'en Afghanistan,
les jeunes qui se battent des deux côtés
ne sont finalement pas si différents.
Parce que le MEND
et autres Robin des Bois
sont des brigands comme les autres.
Parce que les racines de Boko Haram
sont bien plus complexes.
Alors, c'est vrai que
le noir et blanc, c'est plus joli,
c'est plus élégant,
mais c'est simpliste
et puis surtout c'est faux.
La couleur, c'est moins
absolu, c'est plus flou,
mais c'est plus vrai.
Alors moi je veux continuer
à vous faire connaître ces insurgés,
ces révolutionnaires, ces terroristes,
pour que vous puissiez vous faire
une idée en toute connaissance de cause.
Nous les reporters,
nous sommes là pour ça,
et parfois au péril de notre vie.
Aller là où vous ne pouvez pas aller,
vous faire voir ce que parfois
vous n'avez pas envie de voir.
Vous avez droit à la vérité,
alors exigez-la.
(Applaudissements)